we talk about how the United States is
currently being run by children and
usually it's because of the childish way
in which they govern or the childish way
in which they think about geopolitical
issues or the way that they try to
appeal to low information trumpets it's
a very long long list of childish type
behavior but now we have something new
to add to the list the Washington Post
is reporting that Donald Trump regularly
adopts one of those stereotypical fake
Indian accents when talking about or
quoting Indian Prime Minister Narendra
Modi this was part of a follow-up report
to the now infamous [ __ ] country's
report where Donald Trump was
referencing Haiti and El Salvador and
some African countries we know that
Trump did that we know that Trump has
referred to senator Elizabeth Warren as
Pocahontas referencing her Native
American heritage and this is now a new
type of childish using a fake
stereotypical mocking Indian accent when
talking about or quoting the Indian
Prime Minister and I've been careful not
to retroactively Lee normalized george w
bush because george w bush was a
depraved and horrible president but from
the point of view of diplomacy and
optics george w bush was comparatively
like a masterful diplomat compared to
donald trump and that's not a praise of
george w bush it's it's just making a
comparison you really don't want to know
the accents that other world leaders are
using to impersonate trump if you think
that this is bad you should see how they
see Trump's speech in other countries
around the world I never understood
speaking about Trump here for a second
when people speak one language and they
sort of make fun of how people speak
English as a second language or as a
third language I don't find it at all
offensive to joke about accents right
it's a really minor thing it's often in
good fun when it comes to drugs Trump
it's just part of his childish nature
but when you only speak one language and
there's people who can speak two
languages or three and communicate
effective
we put with an accent in those other
languages look what is there to make fun
of it just like it's it's it's quite
impressive actually when people have
multiple languages that they can
communicate it there's no reason to make
fun of them because they still made an
effort to learn your language and can
still communicate with you I actually
find that when people think to make fun
of how someone speaks a language that's
their second language the person doing
the poking fun probably only speaks one
language because when you when you speak
multiple languages you understand how
difficult it is to make yourself
understood sort of in a fluid way in
another language I learned English as a
second language I learned it very young
but my native language is Spanish and
I'm around people who speak with accents
all the time it just doesn't strike me
as funny like I wouldn't even occur to
me to mock them because yet people learn
languages at different ages and you
don't always sound like a native speaker
and I understand you know if it can be
done in a comedic setting and it can be
done in jest but it's certainly not
professional
no and it's certainly not presidential
and it comes across as offensive in some
settings - is it extra funny that trumps
English is terrible and that's the only
language he speaks he speaks at the
lowest grade level of any president in
the modern era of evaluating the level
at which presidents speak and he's
making fun of how other people speak
English there's something weird about
like in my English complex I would say
like one of those complexes yeah it must
have some name I don't know what it
would be but I'm surely gonna sign
assign a name to it remind me Pat at
some point to tell this reminds me I
don't have time to tell it now but the
how do you say cheese in English story I
don't think I've ever told the story
maybe on the bonus so it's a good one
join us on our subreddit where you can
discuss this or any other stories from
today's show david pakman.com slash our
IDI di t today's episode of the david
pakman show is made possible in part by
brilliant if you watch our Channel
you're into politics you follow daily
news but maybe like me you want to also
dig deeper and on the program we talk
about climate change taxes we discuss
technology and political philosophy but
to really understand these issues
at the most fundamental level you have
to familiarize yourself with what's
actually sort of underpinning it all and
that's math and philosophy hard sciences
social sciences and that's where
brilliant comes in brilliant is a truly
unique and innovative online learning
service that allows you to master
important real-world math and science
concepts everything from probability and
statistics to logic and problem-solving
renewable energy climate science
criminology you name it and you can get
started right now
right this second in fact by signing up
for free at brilliant org slash David
Pakman the first 200 people to do so to
sign up through brilliant org slash
David Pakman will also be eligible for
20% off an annual Premium Membership one
more time check out brilliant at
brilliant org slash David Pakman